[Applause]
thank you very much I will now welcome
our guests
[Applause]
president Michelle president
Wonderland Commissioners
dear members thank you
for being with us here in the house of
European democracy
before we hear the speeches of today I
would like to invite all of you to turn
your attention to the screens to watch a
short video in celebration of
international women's day
[Music]
it is not just about empowerment it is
about opportunity opportunity that is
not presented to women because they are
women
but rather in spite of the fact that
they are women they can be who they want
to be the exact kind of leader they want
to be this is my hope for the next
generation of women
what's truly amazing is to be up here in
space and and be able to serve first and
foremost as a crew member of the
International Space Station it was my
dream since I was a small child to one
day be able to fly to space
in her car finished
[Music]
from
many girls cannot go to school
they are neglected but still there is
hope
of confidence in yourself
trust yourself don't let yourself be
intimidated
have what it takes
[Music]
um
misplaces truly where she wants to be be
that standing up in Parliament
heading a law firm presiding a courtroom
or leading a nation to prosperity
[Music]
dear colleagues
International women's day is marked in
our annual calendar not only to
recognize the achievements of women and
girls across the world
but also as a call to action
a rallying point to strengthen gender
equality across all spheres
of our society
I'm so proud to be here as
The Third Woman president of this
institution
and I'm so grateful for those who came
before me who made the path easier
for my generation
for all of us
I am here we are here because of the
battles that they fought for us
we stand on their shoulders
and we reiterate our promise to make it
easier for those who come after us
women have changed the world and we
don't say this enough
we have with us
today Commander Samantha christopheretti
the first European woman
Samantha
is the first European woman to command
the International Space Station
thank you Samantha for showing every
young girl in Europe that they can reach
for the stars
you beat the odds
and you thrived your hard work and
determination are an example to us all
on International women's day
it is important to recognize the
achievements of women and girls around
the world and Beyond
as a source of empowerment and
inspiration for every young girl and yet
even as we've heard in the speeches
we've just
seen the reality is that progress
towards true equality remains painfully
slow and that can no longer be an
acceptable benchmark
so today I want
to honor all those women who are
fighting
for their freedom
and inclusion
women who are killed beaten and abused
all over the world just for being women
all those women still fighting for their
rights all those women who have to face
higher standards and have to prove every
day that they are capable of doing the
job
all the women facing new digital hurdles
online
all those Mothers Daughters sisters who
face obstacles every day that we do not
talk about all those women who face all
this and yet remained remain unbowed
and Unbroken
Ukrainian women fighting against an
illegal Russian invasion who to quote
the first woman president of the
European Commission
smashed a glass ceiling over the head of
the Russian Invaders
the chibok girls kidnapped nine years
ago by Boko Haram in Nigeria
many of whom remain in captivity
they have not been forgotten and our
commitment to bring back our girls
remains as strong today
Afghan woman
who are silenced
repressed mistreated
robbed of their education and who
continue to suffer at the hands of the
Taliban
Iranian women
who are standing up for life
and Liberty and paying the ultimate
price
Dr Shirin abadi is with us today
[Applause]
a Nobel Prize Laureate and one of Iran's
first
female judges Dr abadi we appreciate
the immense effort that you have made to
be with us today
you embody the fight
of Iranian women the fight for what is
fair
and for what is right
your presence is a reminder
that the fight will not cease and that
freedom requires courage and sacrifice
it is also a warning to those who hope
it might
women will not go silently into the
night they will not give up and the
European Parliament will continue to
stand with the women of Iran
dear colleagues my hope is for
international women's day to be seen as
an invitation for societies to do better
even within our Union
gender equality will remain unfinished
business for as long as we have not
achieved equal pay for equal work
today still every second woman around us
has experienced sexual harassment
the time is now for the European Union
to lead by example to such standards in
criminalizing violence against women
to improve access to Justice and to
ratify the Istanbul convention before
the end of this term
when women are free
when rights are respected when education
is recognized when pay is equal
when women are protected
when opportunities are fair and we're
playing fields are level
when we realize that when we are all
equal then we all benefit
that is when we can say that we have
achieved the Milestones Our Generation
has inherited
that is when we can say we have left
this place this Union better than we
found it and we will keep working every
day to see that happen
I now toss the floor to the president of
the European commission Mr Ursula on
their line to take the floor
[Applause]
thank you very much president Roberta
Dr ebari
captain christopheretti
honorable members
what an honor to be here with you today
among women
who have blazed the trail for so many
other women
Dr ibadi for decades you have fought for
women's rights in Iran
they try to silence you
they put you in jail
they forced you into Exile but you kept
fighting with bravery day in Day Out you
are amazing and we thank you for your
leadership
it is outstanding what you've done
today countless women have joined in
your fight
and the whole world stands in awe
of the women in of Iran
more and more women are choosing to defy
the prohibitions of a regime
that does not see them as equal
they take off their headscarves
and for this they get beaten up
put in jail even killed
they too are blazing a trail for their
sisters their mothers their daughters
for all the people of Iran
they are claiming not only the freedom
to show their hair
or to cover it
but also the Freedom From Fear
from violence
freedom to study
to work
to love without asking anybody's
permission as it should be it's women
life liberty that's what you stand for
the fight and the courage of Iranian
women move and Inspire women all across
the world
because the challenges we face
may be different
but the rights we strive for are the
same
first and foremost the most basic of All
Rights the right to be free from
violence
this is still a global curse including
here in Europe
and how can you be equal if you're
constantly under threat
there's massive work to do
to change everyone's mindset
to ensure
that it's never Justified to beat a
woman
that it's never Justified to mutilate a
girl's body
that no always means no
and this is why we're pushing hard
to ensure equal protection to all women
in all European countries and I know
honorable members you share my
aspiration
so let us join forces
let us bring to life
the first ever EU law on combating
violence against women and domestic
violence it's time to deliver
[Applause]
honorable members and distinguished
guests
gender equality
does not just happen
even in countries where there's no
morality police
progress is hard one
easily lost
it requires day-to-day attention and
commitment
to ensure that women and girls are free
from violence
that women as well as men can have both
family and a career
that women earn the same as their male
colleague because they deserve it
that women do reach the very top levels
because they are qualified
we have a duty
to set an example to society and the
economy of what a world of fair chances
looks like
and this Duty counts every day not just
on International women's day
Beyond laws
women and girls also need role models
women who blaze a trail for everyone
else
and that's why I'm so glad to meet you
captain christopheretti
you once said
and I quote
as a child I didn't dream to be the
first Italian women astronaut
I just dreamed to be an astronaut
you just wanted to follow your dreams
and with passion and hard work you made
it
and now girls look up to you
as a role model
thanks to you they know that they too
can Aim High
and just like you they can reach for the
stars
Captain christopheretti Dr ibadi your
examples Inspire us
you strive for a world where young girls
and boys can be whatever they want to be
in life
where there are no jobs that are simply
for men or simply for women
where they're not even the sky is a
limit
this is our goal
and again not because women are better
but because we are different
and also very simply because it is right
this is time for World of equal rights
and fair chances not just for women
but for all of us long live Europe
thank you very much
president Wonderland
I now pass the floor
to miss Samantha Christopher
Madam president matsola
Tierra president Michelle President Van
Der Lyon
dear Dr ibadi
dear members of the European Parliament
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
it is an immense honor for me to be here
today I'm very grateful for the
invitation to participate in the
parliament celebration of international
women's day
and I'm truly humbled by the opportunity
of speaking here today at the center of
our European democracy and decision
making
and I am humbled by the opportunity of
taking the floor
just before Dr ibadi a woman who has
been a true champion of women's rights
in the face of brutal discrimination and
who has suffered terrible personal
consequences for her willingness to
fight and for that I thank you Dr ibadim
thank you
as an astronaut of Issa the European
Space Agency I would like to take this
opportunity to talk to you about what I
know best
which is the European space activities
the role of Isa and the synergists with
the European Union
space is out there
but it's also here among us every day
it's an essential element of everyday
life
we take it for granted sometimes we even
notice it don't notice it and yet space
is woven into the fabric of every modern
society
it is well known that we rely on Space
assets to provide important services
like Earth observation communication
navigation
services that we need
for example for environmental monitoring
to mitigate the consequences of climate
change for weather forecast Disaster
Response internet access TV broadcasting
even smart traffic
space assets are even crucial for energy
provision or financial transactions and
many other vital economic functions
and Isa Works constantly to ensure that
these essential services are secured and
that oral relevant assets are managed
efficiently and remain available
to support the policies that you the
political decision makers set for us
for the benefits of European citizens
be it about climate change the grain
transition the digital transformation
sustainable development or inclusiveness
and let us not forget security
I think that the green political context
that we are facing these days has
highlighted the importance of security
related space activities
and as you know last Friday the
commission and the high representative
presented for the first time a joint
communication on a European strategy for
security and defense a European Space
strategy for security and defense
and the European Parliament will play a
crucial role and Esa will provide its
contribution
a powerful engine of prosperity and
economic growth
today the global space Market is already
worth about
340 billion US dollars
and by the late 2030s by some estimates
space could generate a revenue of 1
trillion US dollars
and such tremendous growth potential can
be in part described to a profound
transformation of our industry often
referred to as the new space Revolution
new players are getting involved often
from outside of the traditional space
sector
old and new companies pursue profit and
growth through novel business models
risk sharing with public institutions
through public private Partnerships
and early financing through venture
capital
the reduction in the cost of access to
space brought about for example by the
reusability of launchers has made Mega
constellations a reality
the miniaturization of electronics has
made satellite platforms smaller and
cheaper and yet more capable and
versatile
let me add however in all honesty that
many of these new space developments are
far more advanced in North America than
they are here in Europe
still the opportunities are there for
Europe to take
if we choose to be ambitious in our
goals and Pursuits
is member states have already raised the
level of ambition
or ministerial meeting last November in
Paris secured a record budget of 16.9
billion euros for the coming three years
that is a 17 increase with respect to
the preceding ministerial back in 2019.
clear sign that our member states
understand space as a strategic
component of our industrial and
technological sovereignty
Issa brings world-class expertise unique
know-how in the area of space science
technology and applications
along with its Rich experience in space
project management
but an ambitious European approach needs
Partnerships with national institutions
Academia industry and with the European
Union
Issa and the European Union each bring
their specific mandates competencies and
strengths to the table
either's agenda 2025 which was published
on the very first day in office of isa's
director General Joseph ashbacher lists
A Renewed and enforced partnership
between Isa and the EU as a top priority
isn't you have embarked on major common
success stories Copernicus the world's
largest and most successful Earth
observation program
providing decision makers researchers
entrepreneurs and the public with
information on the state of our planet
Galileo Europe's own Global navigation
satellite system providing a highly
accurate guaranteed global positioning
service under civilian control
featuring the world's most accurate
navigation system
and the new secure connectivity Iris
Square to program which will provide a
new Sovereign and secure space-based
communication infrastructure in Europe
to improve strategic autonomy digital
resilience security
technological non-dependence and
Commercial competitiveness
many in the European Parliament may not
know but Isa was at the origin of both
Flagship programs Copernicus and Galileo
and Issa is grateful that the EU and the
European Parliament stepped up to the
challenge and enable what have become
two of the world's most successful space
programs
we cannot be proud of these achievements
and is as particularly grateful to
implement these programs together with
the EU
at ISA we have a full agenda this year
among other things we are tackling the
critical European launcher situation
with the top priority of restoring
independent access to space for Europe
in Copernicus were preparing the Next
Generation Sentinel satellites
and we do need to close a funding gap of
721 million euros
the European parliament's support will
be crucial to achieve this
we will also launch two exciting new
science missions Jews to explore the icy
moons of Jupiter in April and Euclid
with which we will better understand
dark matter and dark energy in July
ladies and gentlemen Europe has a rich
history of space achievements including
what is possibly dearest to me in human
space flight
through our partnership in the
International Space Station we have
secured opportunities for Europeans to
fly to space
and for European scientists to do
research in microgravity
we are a strong partner in the nasalet
Artemis program of lunar exploration
providing the European service module
for the Orion spacecraft and a
significant portion of Gateway a space
station that will fly in lunar orbit
together with NASA we intend to retrieve
and bring back to Earth samples of
Martian soil
as a member of the European astronaut
Corps I myself had twice the privilege
of representing Europe in space
[Applause]
Madam president
when we spoke for the first time last
September I was serving as commander of
the International Space Station
first European woman to do so but
certainly not the last
week
at ISA just last year we selected a new
class of career and Reserve astronauts
and over half of them are women
and
[Applause]
and let me add that we selected these
new colleagues of mine out of over 23
000 applicants throughout Europe
this ladies and gentlemen is the power
of space to inspire to spark passions in
our youngsters around Europe
as an astronaut I have witnessed that
many times how space can spark passions
and dreams those passions and dreams
that make our youngsters choose studies
education and careers in science and
technology
so that they acquire those competencies
that are so strategically important for
Europe for our research for our
industrial competitiveness for our
entrepreneurship
I have seen how the ability of sending
human into space acts as a confidence
builder in a society
it builds the confidence that a nation
or a community of Nations like ours can
tackle the really difficult ambitious
challenges
if we can send human into space there's
nothing we cannot do right
let us have that ambition in Europe
[Applause]
I have flown to space twice once on a
Russian soyuz and once on an American
Dragon
twice I have fulfilled my dream of
flying to space
and if I can allow myself at this point
in my life one more dream that dream is
that of seeing one day astronauts flying
on a European Vehicle you're
flying our astronauts to space on our
own vehicle welcoming astronauts from
other parts of the world on our own
European space vehicle it will be a
mighty political strategic cultural
psychological even philosophical symbol
it will be an expression of Europe's
ambition to gain a position in space
that matches Europe's political and
economic weight
it will allow us to continue to
cooperate in international Partnerships
but do that on a more equal level
it will allow us to not miss out on the
enormous strategic and economic
opportunities that space offers
and it will allow us to develop and
retain in Europe vital stamp Talent
and to develop the capabilities but also
the mindset that is needed to solve the
many big challenges that we are facing
for the benefits of the citizens in
Europe and all over the world
let me conclude by recognizing the
important role that the European
Parliament and the itra committee in
particular has played and continues to
play in its consistent support of space
activities
you have been a competent and reliable
partner for Esa in all of our
discussions and negotiations
as well as in the preparation of the
legislative basis for a common space
projects Galileo Copernicus and now Iris
squared
and it is therefore an incredible honor
to be able to hand over today the
European flag that flew with me on the
International Space Station
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much Dear Miss
christopheretti
I now pass the floor to Dr Shirin abadi
[Applause]
oh
ladies and gentlemen
The Honorable
yes
your excellencies
The Honorable president of the European
Union
European Parliament
The Honorable MEPS and
dear guests
and ladies and gentlemen
it is an honor for me to be
among you on such a day I'm once again
addressing
you members of European Parliament
I would like to thank you for having
given me this opportunity
it's an honor for me and
it is
the
as a result of the fight
and
protest by
my people in Iran it was the Iranian
women who started a revolution
as a result of which the voices of the
Iranian people have been heard
throughout the world including
yourselves
and which has guided me to this
chair today from where I'm speaking to
you
as you're all aware
the revolution in Iran was sparked by
the killing of a young girl
who was arrested on the street by the
morality police only because
a part of her hair was visible from
under her scarf and she was killed
and
the family of this
girl
filed a complaint but
to no avail
however the lawyer who was representing
the family of this young girl has been
prosecuted
and
has currently been released on bail
moreover
two young reporters who had published a
photograph of this young girl while she
was lying on a hospital bed
and had
filed a report
on the funeral of this young girl in the
domestic media in Iran
these two journalists
were both arrested on the charge of
espionage
and to date they are still in prison
I am talking about a country
where
its government
kills with impunity
while
the profession of Journalism and the
legal profession is deemed a crime
and of course you representatives of
Europe
I am sure you are well aware of the
conduct of the Islamic Republic
and you know that
how many of your
Nationals are currently
being held hostage in our presence
and unfortunately so far
at least two of them
have been sentenced to death penalty why
because
the government in Iran
by taking
your National you European Nationals
hostage
wants to achieve his political
objectives
in that country what is not important is
Justice because of courts are not
independent and they follow
the security forces
in Iran
and they only implement the ambitious
policies of the regime
and lack of independence of Courts is
one of the most important issues in Iran
in my country Iran
in the past 43 years
a large number of people
have lost their lives for opposing such
a government
now the regime never publishes any
statistics
and we only
find out after verification
from the families of
these victims
and how many have been killed
in this revolution which was sparked by
this young girl called Masa which
started in September 2022
to date
over
550 individuals have been killed
and at least 70 of them
were juveniles under the age of 18.
moreover at least 20
protesters have been arrested
recently in this very month
the Iranian government in a bit to
deceive public opinion they announced
that
pardoned some of these parishioners
of course yes some were pardoned and
released however
what is so tragic is that the same as
the same number of people that released
they went on and arrested exactly the
same number again
and even more importantly
the protesters who were very influential
in these
recent protests remain Behind Bars
freedom of expression in Iran is so
restricted that only
since September 2022 18 lawyers
have been arrested merely for defending
these protesters
they're being prosecuted at the moment
some of them
remain in prison
and
I would like to name one of them
who is a colleague of mine who has been
a colleague of mine and at the moment
he is on Hunger Strike his name is
Muhammad najafi
the rest have been freed on bail
and this
stems from the lack of independence of
the Judiciary in Iran
In This Very week they announced that 35
artists filmmakers
actors and actresses only because they
had supported the people
and supported the protests
have had their assets
and bank accounts
have had their assets confiscated their
bank accounts Frozen
dozens of journalists
bloggers bloggers writers are currently
in prison
why because
freedom of expression in Iran is
extremely
Limited
the people's efforts in the past years
in order to change and reform the status
quo has been in vain
and at the moment the people
continue to Stage their protests which
started in September 2022 and the
people's demand is that the regime be
changed because they know that
unfortunately
this regime cannot be reformed the
constitution of our country has to
change with this current constitution
no reform is possible
and for this very reason
the Iranian people want regime change
and their slogan is a woman life freedom
and this slogan you can look at this
slogan
from two perspectives
you can look at their slogan from two
perspectives the first is
that it Rejects
despotic theocracy in Iran
we do not want a theocracy in Iran
because such a government does not bring
the people welfare or freedom
they have even invaded the privacy of
people in their own homes
and the positive aspect of this slogan
is that
we want a democratic government
in which religion is separate from State
because
after 43 years of experiencing the
Islamic Republic has shown us and the
Muslims in the region
that if
a government
is mixed with ideology or religion how
dangerous
it will become and I this is an
experience and I hope that the other
Islamic countries in the region will
learn from us
now European countries can rest assured
you European states can rest assured
that if
democracies established in Iran in Iran
there will be fewer refugees entering
your countries
currently one of the
main problems of the Iranian people is
immigration
we are suffering from brain drain
there is no employment in Iran
even those who manage to find jobs the
earning is so low that they cannot eke
out a living only yesterday
the chancellor of one of the most
important universities in Iran announced
that only in one year 70 professors have
fled the country and emigrated
now if we have democracy in Iran
the people will no longer need to
emigrate or seek Asylum elsewhere
therefore please support the
establishment of democracy in Iran
because not only that would reduce the
number of refugees in Europe but we will
also be able to build our country
democracy in Iran will be not only to
our benefit but will also
bring about peace and calm in the region
because we the Iranian people oppose the
regime's intervention in other countries
we are against the ambitious policies of
the Iranian regime
we oppose
Iran's nuclear program
they have
spent so much money on this and to no
avail
nuclear bomb will not solve Iran's
problem
or Pro or a problem will only be solved
through democracy democracy I repeat is
not only good for us but it will also be
good for Europe
what I have said is just a small a
fraction of the problems faced by the
Iranian people
I now use this occasion to call on the
Democratic states throughout the world
please do not remain indifferent to the
violation of human rights in Iran please
do not ignore what the Iranian people
are saying
please
do not sign any commercial and trade
contracts with the Iranian government
until the human rights situation in that
country improves
to go in Iran
they signed the jcpoa nuclear Accord
as a result
a great deal of money was sent to Iran
and for three years sanctions were
lifted against Iran
however in those three years the
situation of the Iranian people did not
improve why
because
any money received by the Iranian
government
is either spent on
major embezzlements by the Iranian
regime or it will be used in order to
assist lebanon's Hezbollah
and paramilitary groups in the region
which has disrupted peace in other
countries
you honorable MEPS
have you asked yourself
why the Iranian government has not
joined fatf
have you asked yourself
why
we have not joined the Paloma convention
the answer to this question is very
simple
if they're in government
join their faith you have it will not be
able to continue with its embezzlement
money laundering will end in Iran
therefore Until We join these
conventions please I urge you do not
Forge any contracts with Iran
because
be sure the money will not be spent on
the welfare of the people there is
Extreme poverty in Iran
all right
however the Iranian government wants to
ascribe all these problems to the
sanctions that is not right
the people's poverty stems from
the major embezzlements Corruptions
and the wrong policies of the government
sanctions are effective
and in the recent and in conclusion in
the recent protests
for the first time we saw high school
children taken to the streets to join
the rank of protesters why because they
know that they have no future
Now to create fear and intimidate
those children and their families they
have been using
chemical gases
to poison
young girls school girls at their
schools please write this in your
history books
that what
this regime did
to teenage girls
that they're using
chemical poisonous gases
against women initially the Iranian
government denied these reports they
said oh they're fake you're that's not
happening
however when the number of these girls
who were poisoned grew and their
families and the teachers protested
they said what is going on what
and then
they had to accept that this had
happened
but as usual they gave the usual
rhetoric that this is the work of our
enemies inside and outside the country
and they arrested a few people
but
everyone knows what the real culprit who
the real culprits are
they're not the ones that the government
has arrested pretending they were
responsible
but knowing that these poisoning of the
girls is continuing it shows that those
arrested were not the real culprits
I hope
that my remarks has helped in a way to
convince you honorable MEPS to stand on
the right side of History
please
make sure that the irgc the
Revolutionary guards are named as a
terrorist group
the irgc based on the constitution of
the Islamic Republic of Iran
or
I repeat the irgc based on the
constitution of the Islamic Republic of
Iran
are tasked with protecting the regime
they're separate from the military and
the Army which is to protect
Iran and the people of Iran
these violent acts are being
committed by the irgc
and once again I urge you
do not ignore the widespread violation
of human rights in Iran
democracy in Iran once established not
only will bring calm to Iran but it will
bring peace and calm to the whole region
and without any doubt
the situ the current government in Iran
is not any help for the situation in
Ukraine either thank you very much for
having listened to me thank you
thank you
[Applause]
foreign